you've learned about object localization
as well as landmark detection now let's
build out toward an object detection
algorithm in this video you learned how
to use a confident to perform object
detection using something called the
sliding windows detection algorithm
let's say you want to build a car
detection algorithm here's what you can
do you can first create a label training
set so x and y with closely cropped
examples of cars so this is a image X
that's a positive example as a car is a
car is a car and then there's not a car
that's not a car and for our purposes in
this training set you can start off with
I'm going to call closely cropped images
meaning that X is you know pretty much
only the car so you can take a picture
and crop out and just cut out anything
else there's not part of a car so you
end up with a car centered and in pretty
much the entire image given this labeled
training set given this labeled training
set you can then train a confident that
inputs an image like one of these
closely cropped images and then the job
of the confident is to output y 0 1 is
as a car or not
once you've trained up this confident
you can then use it in sliding windows
detection so the way you do that is if
you have a test image like this what you
do is you start by picking a certain
window sizes are shown down there and
then you would input into this confident
a small rectangular region so take just
this little red square and put that into
the confident and have a confident make
a prediction and presumably for that
little region in the red square will say
no that little red square does not
contain a call in the sliding windows
detection algorithm what you do is you
then process input a second image now
bounded by this red square shifted a
little bit over and feed that to the
confidence you speed in just the region
of the image in the Red Square to the
confident and run the con phonetic game
and then you do that
with a third image and so on and you
keep going until you've you'll slit the
window across every position in the
image and I'm using a pretty large
stride in this example just to make the
animation go faster but the idea is you
basically go through every region of
this size and pass lots of little
crafted images into the confident and
have it classify 0 or 1 for each
position as some stride now having done
this once with running this was called a
sliding window through the image you'd
then repeat it but now use a larger
window so now you take a slightly larger
region and run that region so resize
this region into whatever input size the
continent is expecting and feed that to
the confident and have it output 0 1 and
then slide the window over again using
some stride and so on and you run that
throughout your entire image until you
get to the end and then you might do the
third time using even larger windows and
so on and the hope is that if you do
this then so long as there's a car
somewhere in the image that there will
be a window where for example if you
were passing in this window into the
confident hopefully the confident will
have output 1 for that input region so
then you detect that there is a car
there so this algorithm is called
sliding windows detection because you
take these windows these some square
boxes and slide them across the entire
image and classify every square region
with some stride as containing a car or
not now there's a huge disadvantage of
sliding windows detection which is the
computational cost because you're
cropping out so many different square
regions in the image and running each of
them in the
inde through a confident and if you use
the very course write a very big Strider
very big step size then that would
reduce the number of windows you need to
pass through the continent but that
coarser granularity may hurt performance
whereas if you use a very fine
granularity or a very small stride then
the huge number of you know all these
little regions you're passing through
the confident means that there's a very
high computational cost so before the
rise of neural networks people used to
use much simpler classifiers like a
simple linear classifier overhand
engineer features in order to perform
object detection and in that error
because each classifier was relatively
cheap to compute it was just a linear
function sliding windows detection ran
okay it was not a bad method but with
confidence now running a single
classification task is much more
expensive and sliding windows this way
is infeasible slow and unless you use a
very fine granularity or a very small
stride you end up not able to localize
the objects that accurately within the
image as well fortunately however this
problem of computational cost has a
pretty good solution in particular the
sliding windows object detector can be
implemented convolutional e or much more
efficiently let's see in the next video
how you can do that